bild ist weiterhin an der front unsere
reporter reisen dorthin wo der krieg
tobt in den osten der ukraine nach
vielen rückschlägen ist putins
invasionsarmee dort langsam auf dem
vormarsch in wach mut haben mehrere
tausend menschen aus obwohl die
russische armee im norden süden und
osten nur einige kilometer entfernt ist
die gefahr eine einkesselung der
ukrainischen einheiten wir sind hier im
donbass in der nähe von mahmut einer
kleinstadt die unweit der gefechts zone
liegt unweit dieses kessels den die
russische streitkräfte zu legen
versuchen um ein größeres gebiet um
mehrere ukrainische einheiten
einzukesseln während im hintergrund die
ganze zeit artilleriegefechte direkt
hinter uns liegt auch eine fabrik des
deutschen herstellers knauf die zerstört
wurde und wir haben auf dem weg hierhin
immer wieder auch ukrainische einheiten
gesehen die versuchen hier ihre defensiv
positionen auszubauen
teilweise auch mit schwerer artillerie
allerdings sind diese ukrainischen
einheiten momentan deutlich deutlich in
die defensive geraten haben sich jetzt
zwar eingegraben aber es ist ein
schwerer abwehrkampf vor ihnen her bevor
steht
einige kilometer östlich von bach liegt
ein großer fabrik komplex des deutschen
herstellers knaus viele der gebäude sind
zerstört
in den vergangenen tagen haben russische
truppen das gelände immer wieder
beschossen auch am montag liegt der
typisch verbrannte geruch
eingeschlagener raketen in der luft
[Musik]
mahmut die straßen der frontstadt sind
menschenleer obwohl mehrere tausend
menschen hier ausharren sollen viele von
ihnen sind flüchtlinge aus den
umliegenden ortschaften aber auch einige
einwohner sind geblieben sowie roman und
seine tochter sonja
vor drei tagen wurde unser wohnblock
bombardiert es liegen immer noch
glasscherben auf der straße wir müssen
deshalb vorsichtig laufen
er und seine frau arbeiten als
immobilienmakler beide kümmern sich
jetzt um ältere leute in ihrer
nachbarschaft wir können nicht gehen
doch als er auf seine tochter sonja
schaut kommen ihm die tränen
sie weiß dass es gefährlich hier ist
romans tochter ist acht jahre alt
momentan kann sie nur am fernunterricht
teilnehmen spielt ansonsten mit ihren
verbliebenen freundin und hund archie
während neben ihr ukrainische
militärfahrzeuge vorbeifahren den
einwohnern von bach mit stehen wohl
düstere tage bevor anders als die
russische armee die immer mehr schweres
gerät an die front fährt sind die
ressourcen der ukraine begrenzt zwar
sind auch hier bereits amerikanische m
777 haubitzen im einsatz doch es ist
ungewiss wie lange die ukrainischen
verteidiger damit ihre
verteidigungslinie noch halten können
unser reporter bian stritzel ist
weiterhin in der ukraine unterwegs sind
wird uns auch weiterhin im laufe dieser
sendungen mit informationen versorgen